[Music]
we are lady parts
here's a little something we thought you
might like
that is me 26 capricorn finishing a phd
in
microbiology
and this is lady parts a confused mix of
hash anthems and sour girl power
our sound is thin we need something more
we need lead guitarist
we don't need a wanky self-indulgent
guitar soloist
over
who would have thought that our orbits
were soon to collide you
you went to son abigail's primary school
you played guitar in the talent show
you got expelled for selling school
furniture vera lead his eye
play something play something i don't
perform
my nerfy disposition induces diary and
vomiting
ew i vowed i would never perform again
but lady parts had other plans she's our
[Music]
it guitarist kind of like therapy but
with a lot of screaming
[Music]
you got a problem with my lyrics you
could do less
more
to our newest band number a delightful
freak show
and our great new friend am i really
that bad
you're that good
we're sisters our music is about
representation
it's about being heard
[Music]
you're in a punk band yes ma and you
haven't been
or
this is us buy us for us
you